hey folks Chris waters here with Erin
Sampson and we are gonna be talking
about battlefield payday mode
battlefield gt5 outfield Omaha
battlefield hardline huge leak this
morning it was teased a little bit
earlier this week but now we've got a
seven minute trailer out in the wild
describes game modes single-player
campaign weapons vehicles
destructibility all that stuff so as to
the resident gamespot battlefield
aficionados we're gonna give you our
take on it and tell you what we're
excited about so Aaron the thing we've
been talking about the most I think
grappling hooks yeah so we're seeing a
return of the grappling hook from
battlefield two special forces I like
the idea of unpredictability and that's
something that's always been a strong
point in battlefield you give players a
set of tools and they do crazy stuff
with it you never know where somebody's
gonna grapple to so I see that as you
know positive direction for this game
yeah definitely a way to make these sort
of heist scenarios and these these urban
encounters more dynamic just because you
know not there you don't need no they're
gonna be coming from the same three
places I guess would be the idea just to
give it a larger overview for anybody
who hasn't seen the trailer battlefield
hardline is a cops and robbers
battlefield maybe like semi close
quarters to medium matte mm-hmm combat
well they showed a couple different
scales of map and of course the close
quarters one are these heist mode this
vault incursion where the criminals are
trying to crack the safe and then escape
while the cops are assaulting them and
trying to keep them from getting out
those maps seem to have you know
obviously big downtown areas roads and
buildings to infiltrate through and then
escaping on motorcycles presumably
there's some sort of escape radius or
destination once you've grabbed the loot
you get out and you're gone so we did
see car chases with multiple types of
vehicles we saw like a big suburban with
a minion on top with your motorcycles we
saw police cars I didn't see an RPG so
you're gonna have to watch out for those
a skillful RPG shooters yeah cuz one RPG
and [ __ ] your getaway yes you got god
that's hot wire mode one of the other
modes a announced in the trailer and
that's
basically a car chase mode so those maps
were sprawling they looked actually like
the kind of like methi desert towns that
trevor in GTA 5 is from like just a lot
of open space to drive through as well
as you know building to sort of weave
your way around dirt roads paved roads
and a lot of open air space with low
buildings for helicopters it's the type
of combat that tactical intervention
that the game from the ex counter-strike
creator and sort of was going for didn't
quite pull it off so I'm excited to see
that idea done in frostbite I guess yeah
be interesting to see cuz like they'll
have to find a way to keep you going
around the map because it can't just be
a point A to point B I feel like maybe
some checkpoints involved who knows what
the details are going to be on how that
mode plays out specifically a couple
other modes we the trailer delineated
one was rescue and that's seemed like
the sort of the flip side of the the
heist whereas instead of the criminals
trying to steal something get out the
SWAT team the cops are trying to rescue
hostages from robbery gone wrong and
then get them out so those both seemed a
little bit parallel to me in terms of
sort of their scope and their the the
way there that they might play out and
certainly the maps in which that might
happen and then of course the fourth one
was blood money and this is almost like
a reminding me of a neutral bomb like
destruction plant the bomb mode like
alliteration obliteration yeah so it's
there's a cash pile in the map somewhere
cops and robbers are both trying to grab
cash bring it back to their safe houses
so there's that you know do I play
defense on the cash do I play defense
back at my base do I play defense at the
enemy base you know to keep them from
getting calorie cash you know that sort
of seems a little bit more putting them
you know putting them on par as equals
in terms of they both have the same
objective where the other modes are
lopsided both the cops and robbers will
have differing objectives now the game
also is gonna have a single player
campaign and possibly co-op we saw a
shot of four screens together but it's
unclear if they were talking about like
you can approach a mission in different
ways every time yeah that was an
indicator of there was like
or player split screen co-op it look
really split screen e to me I mean that
language of the four screen split evenly
that screams cooperative play to me and
but you know they did say you can play
these missions out in multiple ways so
maybe it was like you can try this way
you could do this way you can do that
way or this way that's a little unclear
from the leaked trailer up but
single-player campaign is gonna play out
like an episodic like cop procedural
show where you're you're Nick Mendoza
lots of gangster swag yeah previously on
hardline your we are wild and crazy
partner took all this coke money and now
you got to pursue him across the country
you've had that call far as vibes yeah
yeah yeah so there and they've got they
made a sort of focus on having not like
actors that have been Inge there in
current TV shows you know bringing their
act their performance muscle to the show
and this is of course Visceral Games
working with dice and so you know if you
think to previous battle field campaigns
storytelling character was not like
their strong suit particularly ah seems
like with the visceral games pedigree
and their dead space stuff that this
trailer was certainly trying to play out
this storytelling in the single-player
campaign in hardline except for this I
want my laptop seen I want my laptop
what's that about bad enough Aaron let's
talk real quick about the gadgets and
weapons that we sort of saw in there
because there were scenes that I there
was a Taser shot there was a subdued of
a criminal with a handcuffed and you
know i'm not sure if those were part of
the campaign or part of multiplayer but
it seems like with non-lethal ways to
subdue your foes being shown in the
trailers that might be part of the game
like if you can maybe she can
non-lethally subdue a criminal and bring
them to an extraction point their
respawn timer is different or something
like that let's just talk i guess in a
more general way about battlefield
mechanics how are they going to
translate to this kind of lopsided
objective modes to this closer quarters
i mean we certainly seen close quarters
battle field in recent years so this
might end up being sort of the again
like I think we've always when we saw
close quarters come to battlefield 3 I
think what we always just wanted
is a larger map so we wanted the
expansive interiors we wanted all the
detail we wanted the like urban warfare
which is really cool i mean you can
honestly only do so much battle in a
field I mean you really would like to
fight endure sometimes and players in
battlefield have always loved the close
quarters maps here's a huge following
for Metro the huge falling for operation
locker so I think you know the people
who want their battlefields tighter with
the game modes closer the firefights
little bit more intense and let's spread
out are gonna get a something out of
this game I think they might really
enjoy it ya know it seems and what I
really like is the obvious comparisons
I've made a joke about earlier but
payday 2 that was a game in which
working together with you know with your
up fellow criminals to accomplish this
sort of multi tiered heist goal against
sort of the waves and waves of cops was
a really engaging experience and so you
know battlefield team work as always
you've had to bring a little bit more to
the table to make it happen right you
want to team up with a squad of people
who are chatting you want to get in
there with some of your friends and play
but that kind of coordination you know
towards a specific goal as opposed to
just like our well we need to capture
point see we need to grab the bottom
bring it back but like if there's more
stuff you know blow this wall to get
into the vault or try to crack the vault
here and there's a little more gadget
play and certainly moving around the the
grappling hooks I think there's cool
opportunities for that kind of squad
teamwork and again like Battlefield
players have always loved destruction
but they loved it within the context of
a match it's not just like a this wall
crumbles it crumbles because you're
trying to get somewhere yeah so you know
again vault cracking destroying walls
all that is in a positive direction for
and they did use the word again
l'évolution they said it but a good
direction for the game and good way to
use LEvolution yeah I think letting you
know will that be the safe door opens
and that's the level because you've
reached the certain criteria or you know
are we gonna get more of these tactical
sort of flexibility spaces where you can
blow your way through a wall you can
like you know grapple hook up to a roof
bust into a stairwell and now you're
coming from a different way that the
cops have to keep covered now you did
mention payday 2 i will say that I'm
cheers to see what x lead developer at
dice David Goldfarb has to say who left
dice and battlefield to make payday 2
yeah you kind of went that criminal way
before dice themselves are now going off
criminal not that he's a criminal I
didn't that was a weird phrasing anyways
yeah we'll try to get in touch with him
see what he has to say about it but
we're curious to know you folks think of
hardline the leak of course a few weeks
in advance of e3 will be seen it
properly showing off their hopefully
maybe play a little bit we shall see but
let us know what you think in the
comments below and share any questions
you have hopefully we can get them
answered